[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم في
العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه البدايه
من امام وزاره العدل الامريكيه في العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن بعد اعلانه لائحه اتهاما
بحق الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اتهامه
لتعريض بعض الاسرار الامنيه الاكثر حساسيه
في البلاد للخطر
والعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم قبل ساعات فقط
من بدء هدنه جديده وافق عليها طرفان
القتال الدائر هناك منذ اسابيع وسط
استمرار المعارك في مواقع متفرقه
والعاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت واعلان الجيش
اللبناني الاستنفاره بعد توتر عن الحدود
مع اسرائيل كسر اطلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي
قنابل الغاز المسيله للدموع على محتشين
وفي مواضيع الحساد لهذه الليله
منعطف في ملاحقات ترامب القضائيه توجيه 37
تهمه فيدراليه للرئيس الامريكي السابق
ابرزها التامر على العداله والاحتفاظ
بمعلومات تتصل بالامن القومي تضمنت خطه
عسكريه ودفاعيه والادلاء بشهادات كاذبه
ترامبيانفي ويعتبر الاتهامات تدخل في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وبايضا ينفي اجراء اي
اتصال مع وزاره العدل بخصوص هذه القضيه
قبل ساعات من بدء هدنه جديده مدتها يوم
وافق عليها طرفان نزاع في السودان
بدوي انفجارات عنيفه وتحليق لطائرات سلاح
الجو شرقي الخرطوم ومعارك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع جنوبيه
الخرطوم وتطورات ميدانيه في ولايه جنوب
كردوغان تنذر باتساع نطاق الصراع
[موسيقى]
توتر على الحدود اصابه متظاهرين
اللبنانيين باختناق اثر اطلاق الجيش
الاسرائيلي قنابل غاز مسين للدموع تجاههم
خلال احتجاجات وسط انتشار متبادل للجيشين
اللبناني والاسرائيلي على الحدود وقوات
اليونيفال تدعو لضبط النفس وتجنب التصعيد
احتدام المعارك على طول الجره في جنوب
اوكرانيا وبوتين يقول ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد بدا ويقلل من اهميته البيت الابيض
يقول ان روسيا تلقت مئات المسيرات
الايرانيه لاستخدامها في مهاجمه اوكرانيا
وعلى هامش الصراع محادثات بين رئيسى
الاركان الروسي والصيني لتعزيز الشراكه
العسكريه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم التصعيد الاخير
والخطير الحاصل في السودان لا سيما في
ولايه جنوب كردفان رغم اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في تلك المنطقه لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي السؤال يقول في رايكم ما هي
ابرز التداعيات المحتمله للتصعيد الميداني
في ولايه جنوب كردفان بالسودان جاءت
الاجابات على الشكل التالي صوت نحو خمسه
وخمسين بالمئه بالقول ان الصراع في
السودان ياخذ ابعادا اخطر بينما قال نحو
11% ان التداعيات هي دفع طرفي الصراع هناك
للتسريع بابرام تسويه
واخيرا صوت 34% لصالح خيار بقاء الاوضاع
كما هي على حالها
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد كالعاده
يوميا تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوديا
[موسيقى]
نشرت وزاره العدل الامريكيه لائحه الاتهام
الصادره بحق الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في قضيه الوثائق السريه حيث سيواجه ترامب
وفقا اللائحه سبعا
تتعلق بحيازه وثائق سريه وعرقله سير
العداله واصدار بيانات كاذبه كما جاء في
لائحه الاتهام ان السجلات السريه التي عثر
عليها في منزل ترامب تضمنت تفاصيل حول
قدرات نوويه لدوله اجنبيه والعثور على عده
وثائق تتعلق بانشطه عسكريه امريكيه وكذلك
اجنبيه كما جاء في اللائحه ان الاتهامات
الموجهه لترامب تتضمن الاحتفاظ بمعلومات
الدفاع الوطني بمحض اراده
انتهاك هذه القوانين تعرض البلد للخطر
وهذا ضد مبادئ العداله
وينبغي ان يكون مثالا لذلك وضعنا
القوانين وهذه القوانين تنطبق على الجميع
اذا سيتم جمع المعلومات وايجاد الوقائع لا
شيء اكثر ولا شيء اقل
وفي سياق ردي على هذه الاتهامات قال
الرئيس الامريكي السابق في تغريده عبر ان
المدعي الخاص في قضيته يكرهه شخصيا ولا
ينبغي ان يكون مشاركا في اي مساله تتعلق
بالعداله كذلك انا من المسيح له احضار
سجلاته الشخصيه من البيت الابيض بموجب
قانون السجلات الرئاسيه مضيفه ان احدا لم
يقل ان من غير المسموح له احضار تلك
السجلات واضاف ترامب في سلسله تغريدات انه
لم يكن لديه ما يخفيه ولا يزال كذلك متهما
الرئيس جو بايدن بنقل عدد من صناديق
الوثائق الى كل مكان بما في ذلك الحي
السيني وحتى مكتب محاميه في بوسطن وفق
تعبيرها وتساءلت ترامب عن عدم نظر المدعي
الخاص في ذلك
وفق قوله
ينضم الينا الان من امام مقر وزاره العدل
في واشنطن مراسلنا مراد هاشم ومن مقر
انعقاد مؤتمر الحزب الجمهوري في نورس
كارولاينا مراسلتنا بسان ابو كويك اهلا بك
مراد كيف تتفاعل هذه القضيه
مرحبا محمد نعم الحديث الان بات في اغلبه
عن لائحه الاتهام وعن ما ورد فيها
والكثير مما ورد فيها في الواقع صادم بل
انه يقدم صوره مروعه في الواقع كما وصفت
لرئيس سابق مستهتر كما قيل يتعامل مع
وثائق في غايه السريه في على نحو
مدان في القانون بشكل واضح هذه اللائحه
تضم 37 تهمه
بينها واحد واحد وثلاثين تهمه جميعها
تتعلق بانتهاك قانون التجسس اي الاحتفاظ
بوثائق تتعلق باسرار دفاعيه عسكريه بشكل
متعمد فيما تتعلق التهم السته الباقيه
الاخرى بعرقله العداله وتضليلها وعدم
التعاون معها ورفض التعاون معها
مع اخرين والادلاء بيانات كاذبه
وبالتالي التسليط الضوء هنا اكثر على ما
يتعلق
بال 31 تهمه تحديدا لانها تتعلق بواحد
وثيقه السريه او في غايه السريه دفاعيه
تتضمن اسرارا تتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي وكذلك بحلفاء للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يتهم الرئيس السابق بانه تعامل
معها بشكل
مستهتر
ويمكن الوصول اليه من قبل من ليس لديهم اي
تصريح امني اضافه الى انه حاول في الواقع
ان يحول دون ان تصل هذه الوثائق ان تعود
في الواقع الى الحكومه الامريكيه في مجمل
هذه لاهحه اتهام وفقا للقانون الامريكي
لدات رمز روايه اخرى بطبيعه الحال يعتبر
نفسه بريئا ان ما يجري هو ملاحقه سياسيه
محمد نعم ماذا عن ماذا عن الصدا في اوساط
الجمهوريين
محمد يعني بعد من الذين تحدثت عليهم هنا
في هذا المؤتمر
يعتبرون حتى لو كانت ترامب ليس هو مرشحهم
المفضل في السباق التمهيدي لمرشح الحزب
الجمهوري ولكنهم يرون ان هناك بالفعل
توظيف لوزاره العدل الامريكيه ومكتب
التحقيقات
الفيدرالي موصفين من يعني وجهوا هذه التهم
الى ترامب ابياء المجرمين وانا وزاره
العدل ليست الا مستنقع طبعا هذا المؤتمر
سيتحدث فيه ترامب مساء يوم غد وقبله
سيشارك في مؤتمر مماثل في ولايه جورجيا
وستكون هي المره الاولى التي يظهر بها
ترامب علنيا وعلى الاغلب سيوظف المؤتمرين
لصالحه لحشد الدعم له وسيظهر ايضا الليله
راند سانتوس احد خصوم ترامب في سباق
الانتخابات التمهيديه وغدا ايضا وستكون
المره الاولى التي يجتمع فيها المرشحين
الثلاثه والذين يعني نلفت الى
رغم هج على ترامحينا اعلن حملته
الانتخابيه اقل اليوم عصر اليوم انه منزعج
من هذه التهم وانه كان يريد من وزاره
العدل ان ترى مسارا اخر او تتخذ مسارا اخر
ولكنه عاد ليكرر انا لا احد فوق القانون
بالنسبه
القانون الفيدرا بشكل مسيس ولملاحقه
الخصوم السياسيين هو الاداء القاتله
للمجتمعات الحره وانه اذا انتخب سيتعامل
مع هذا الامر وسيسائل من قاموا واتخذوا
خطوات تصب في هذا الاتجاه لذا نرى انه رغم
التنافس الان الذي يحتدم في انتخابات
التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري لنيل اسم المرشح
ترامب ما زال الاعلى في
باستطلاعات الراي وحتى خصومه يكررون بعض
ما يقول بان هذه ملاحقه وتسييس
لوزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
للاف بي اي شكرا لك بيسان وشكرا لك مراد
هذا هو يعاقب القانون الامريكي بالسجن
لفترات متفاوته على التهم الموجهه للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
يتجن لمده اقصاها عشر سنوات من يحتفظ بشكل
متعمد بمعلومات الدفاع الوطني والسجن
لعشرين عاما لتهمه المؤامره لعرقله
العداله وبالاحتفاظ بوسائق اوسجلات حكوميه
امريكيه وكذلك من يثبت اتهامه بحجب
المستندات او السجلات والمده ذاتها لمن
يدان باخفاء مستند او سجل بشكل غير امن
اما التخطيط لاخفاء المستندات فيعاقب
عليها القانون بالسجن لمده اقصاها خمس
سنوات والمده ذاتها لمن يدلي باقوال كاذبه
هذا وقد افادت وسائل اعلامنا امريكيه بان
محاميه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب قدموا
استقالتهم واعلنت تكليف فريق جديد للدفاع
عنه وجاءت هذه الاستقاله قبل ايام قليله
من مثول ترامب امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في
ميامي المقرره ليوم الثلاثاء المقبل
وقد قالت شبكه سي ان انها حصلت على تسجيل
صوتي للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب يعترف
فيه بانه احتفظ فعلا بمعلومات عسكريه سريه
لم يرفع عنها او لم ترفع عنها السريه
واوضحت سي ان التسجيل الاجتماعا وقع عام
قال فيه انه كان بامكانه رفع السريه عن
تلك المعلومات حينما كان رئيسا لكنه لم
يعد يستطيع القيام بذلك الان وذكرت الشبكه
ان ترامب كان يناقش في التسجيل الصوتي
خلال الاجتماع وثيقه سريه للبنتاجون بشان
مهاجمته ايران
نشرت وزاره العدل الامريكيه صورا للصناديق
المكدسه في منتجع مارلاجو الخاص بالرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ويعتقد انها
تحتوي على المستندات التي تمت مصادرتها
ينضم الينا من فيرجينيا كريس اديسون استاذ
الحكومه والقانون الدستوريه في الجامعه
الامريكيه وينضم الينا من كاليفورنيا
الرئيس السابق للحزب الجمهوري في
كاليفورنيا والذي نبدا به
نساله عما يعتقد في الاوساط الجمهوريه من
ان كل ما يجري الان ليس الا مؤامره سياسيه
ضد ترامب ما الدليل على ذلك
نحن نتحدث عن رساله
سلط الضوء عليها عدد كبير من الجمهوريين
لفتره طويله حول استخدام الحكومه كالسلاح
وهناك امثله استخدمت فيها العداله بهذا
الغرض ولكن بالنسبه الى هذه الحاله يمكننا
ان نقول ان هذه الوثائق ما كان يجب ان
تخرج من البيت الابيض وان يتم التعامل
معها بطريقه غير سليمه ونتحدث عن تهمتين
التهمه الاولى تعالج امام محكمه الراي
العام والثانيه امام محكمه القانون في
الاوساط الجمهوريه سوف يتحدث الجمهوريون
عن ان هذه العمليه غير عادله ويشيرون الى
مسؤولين في السابق لم يتعرضوا للمحاكمه
اذا نفس الافعال نعم ضيفنا في فرجينيا
السيد
كريسون ما الردود التي يمكن ان تقال
لاثبات ان ما يجري في الولايات المتحده
الان هو فقط ارساء للقانون ليس اكثر
هذا مذكور في لائحه الاتهام بما في ذلك
التسجيلات الصوتيه والرسائل النصيه والصور
بالاضافه الى الملاحظات الخاصه
بمحاميه ترامب ونحن نتحدث عن ادله دامخه
نتحدث عن قضيه خطره للغايه قد يقول
الجمهوريون ان الرؤساء الاخرين قاموا بنفس
الشيء ولكن هذا غير صحيح ان ترامب رفض ان
يعيد هذه الوثائق ولقد تامر بالاضافه الى
ذلك مع موظفا في مكتبه
لاخفاء هذه المستندات والوفائق عن اجهزه
الحكومه نحن نتحدث عن ادله دامغه قويه
وخطره للغايه الغريب سيد ادرسون ان
القانون الامريكي لا يمنع شخص ملاحق او
حتى صدرت بشانه احكام قضائيه من الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه ماذا لو كل هذه
القضيه شكلت دفع دعائيه لترامبو فاز
انت على حق سيدي يمكن ان يخوض غمار السباق
الرئاسي وحتى قد يعتبر ان هذا من شانه ان
يعطيه الحصانه لقد ذكر الضيف الاخر محكمه
الراي العام عدد من الجمهوريين يتحدثون عن
ملاحقه غير عادله وان دونالد ترامب يتم
التصرف معه بطريقه غير عادله ولكن النقطه
الايجابيه هي ان بعض الجمهوريين من مثل
السيد متر رامني
ليسوا لا يوافقون على هذا الموضوع قال
السيد رامي اننا نتحدث عن مشكله خطره
للغايه دونالد ترامب ارتكب خطا كبيرا عدد
من الجمهوريين اشاروا الى هذا الموضوع بما
في ذلك
بالاضافه الى حاكمه اركنسا السابقه
وبالتالي لا نتحدث عن انقساما بين الحزبين
فقط هناك عدد من الذين يقرون بان هذه
التهم خطره للغايه ونامل ان اعداد هؤلاء
سوف ترتفع نحن لا نتحدث عن مساله سياسيه
نتحدث عن مساله امن قومي والرئيس ترامب لا
يمكنه ان يكون في سده الرئاسه هكذا سيد هل
هل يمكن ان نصل في النهايه الى المثل الذي
يقول دعايه سيئه قد تصبح دعايه جيده في
النهايه
في الحقيقه الامر يتوقف على كيفيه تعريفنا
للدعايه السيئه والدعايات
الايجابيه هناك عدد من الداعمين
للرئيس ترامب الذين سوف يستمرون بدعمه
ويضخ الاموال لدعم حملته ولكن في اي مره
يدان فيها مرشح رئاسي هذا امر غير جيد او
يوجه اليه لائحه اتهام هذا امر غير جيد
هناك تركيز كبير على خلفيه كل المرشحين
واذا ما كان اي مرشح يتعرض للمحاكمه هذا
امر يؤدي الى تشتيت الحمله بشكل كبير
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان العمليه الانتخابيه
يمكن ان تجري بطريقه طبيعيه بالتزامن مع
هذا الامر هذا يشتت التركيز عن الحمله
الرئاسيه قد يكون هناك بعض الاستفاده ولكن
بشكل عام نحن نتحدث عن امر سلبي سوف يعرقل
قدره الرئيس السابق ترامب بخوض غماره
الاستحقاق الرئاسي شكرا لكما رن من
كاليفورنيا
من فرجينيا
[موسيقى]
ساعات تفصلنا عن هدنه جديده في السودان
لمده 24 ساعه للمره بينما تستمر المعارك
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
الجنوبي وشرقي الخرطوم التوتر ينتقل الى
ولايه جنوب كردفان حيث قال مصدران مطلعان
للجزيره ان قوات الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان شمال بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو
احتلت منذ يوم الاربعاء الماضي اربعه
مواقع رغم اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار يشمل
تلك المنطقه
كما هو الحال يوميا تتواصل المعارك بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم ومواقع اخرى ويتحدث مراسل الجزيره
عن وقوع انفجارات عنيفه في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم وتحليق طائرات الجيش في اجواء
شرقها ووسطها
بينما تستمر الحرائق لليوم الثالث على
التوالي في منشاه للنفط والغاز عقب هجوم
على مجمع اليرموك العسكري للصناعات
الدفاعيه جنوبيه الخرطوم
عضو مجلس السياده شمس الدين كباشي قال
خلال ظهور علني له ان الجيش يقاتل ضد غزو
اجنبي وان قوات الدعم السريع من ادواته
وانها اشعلت الحرب وتنهب ممتلكات
المواطنين حاليا قواتنا في
كل مكان
[موسيقى]
اي كلام فارغ واي شعاع
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه
توصل الطرفين في المحادثات الجاريه برعايه
امريكيه سعوديه الى اتفاق جديد لوقف اطلاق
النار يستمر 24 ساعه تبدا من صباح السبت
ويهدف الاتفاق لكسر حاله العنف الراهن
وتيسير وصول المساعدات قالت الوزاره ان
الطرفين سيلتزمان بوقف الهجمات والقص
المدفعي والجوي وعدم استخدام الطائرات
المسيره وعدم تحريك القوات او اعاده
تمركزها او امدادها وان الطرفين متفقان
على هدف الهدنه بالسماح بحريه الحركه
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لجميع انحاء
البلاد
ومع التزام الطرفين بالهدنه وهدفها اعترف
الجيش بامدها القصير وقال انه يحتفظ بحق
التعامل مع اي خروق ودعا مستشار بقوات
الدعم السريع الجيش لتقدير معاناه
المواطنين بسبب ما وصفها بالحرب التي
فجرها طبعا في الذاكره فشل كل الهدى
المبرم منذ السادس من مايو وتعثر تحقيق
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار وتظل الاحوال
الامنيه متدهوره ايضا في عدد من الولايات
في جنوب كردفان قال مصدران مطلعان للجزيره
ان قوات الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان
شمال بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو وهي حركه
مسلحه لم توقع على اتفاق جبهه تحتل منذ
يوم الاربعاء اربعه مواقع في الولايه رغم
الهدنه المبرمه بينها وبين الخرطوم
وانضمت شمال كردفان لمثيلاتها ولايات
دارفور وتدهور الوضع المعيشي والصحي في
عاصمتها الاوبيض وقالت نقابه اطباء
السودان ان الابيض محاصره عسكريا من مختلف
الجهاد وناشدت المنظمات الدوليه الاسراع
بفتح ممرات امنه لاسعاف المدينه من اجل
ايصال المواد الغذائيه ومختلف ضروريات
الحياه اليها
والثابت اذا هو استمرار تدهور الاوضاع
واتساع رقعتها دون بروز اي دلائل لوقف
الحرب وان الجهود تقزمت واصبحت الان مجرد
هدنه مدتها 24 ساعه ودون الحديث عن اي
اليه تضمن صمودها واحترام الطرفين لبنودها
وانضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين
بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اهلا وسهلا بك هذه الهدنه الجديده التي
تبدا تقريبا بعد ست ساعات او سبع ساعات هل
سيكون مصيرها افضل من السابقات ليست هنالك
مؤشرات تقول بان هذه الهدنه يمكن ان يقوم
مصيرها افضل ما لم يتحقق في تلك الايام
التي اعلنت في السارق منه هدى لا اتوقع ان
يتحقق في ساعات خاصه وان قوات الدعم
السريع الى حد كبير تفتقد القياده
المركزيه صحيح هنالك مجموعات من الدعم
السريع لها ارتباط بالقياده وتقوم بعمليات
واضح انها مرتب ومنسق لها ولكن هنالك
مجموعات كثيره الان انسحبت من الخرطوم الى
الى الولايات وانسحبت الى دارفور وهي تشعل
الحروب القبليه في دارفور وهنالك مجموعات
تخصصت فقط في النهب والسلب
والغنائم المنزليه
اذا التزمت المجموعه
المرتبطه بالقياده
الاحتمال الا لا تلتزم تلك المجموعات
المتفلته اصلا والتي تتحرك اصبحت باجنده
قبليه في دارفور وباجندا متعلقه بين النهب
واللصوصيه في الخرطوم الوسيط الامريكي
السعودي اعتبر هذه الهدنه فقط للمسائل
الانسانيه ولتعزيز الثقه نوعا مالي عوده
محادثات جدا واذا تم خرقها فهذا يعني ان
لا محادثات في جده هذا الضغط يمكن ان يلعب
دورا لا اظن بهذه الحاله الميدانيه التي
وصفتها قبل قليل لا اعتقد ان الاستجابه
ستكون افضل من الاستجابات السابقه والتي
كانت محدوده الى حد كبير جدا بل كان هنالك
تجاوز كبير في بعض الاحيان اثناء الهدن
فما لم يتحقق في الايام لا اتوقع ان يتحقق
في ساعات خاصه كما قلت لك قبل قليل هذه
الحاله التي يعاني منها
الدعم السريع
البؤره الاخرى ولايه جنوب كردفان هذا
الانفجار الجديد في الوضع هناك ما دلالته
لم الاوضاع في جنوب كردفان الى مرحله
الانفجار هي منظرات بان هنالك خطر قد ياتي
المعلومات الاوليه التي توفرت بان اسباب
هذه الاحتكاك العسكري محليه محضى متعلقه
باحتكاكات مباشره بين الاطراف ولكن ليس من
المستبعد ان يحاول عبد العزيز الحلو حركه
تحرير السودان شمال السودان ان يستغل هذه
الفرصه التي يشتغل فيها الجيش السوداني
بالحرب في الخرطوم وان يحاول ان يتمدد
خاصه وان للرجل نزوع انفصاليه يريد ان
يتوسعوا وله طموح في ان يكون هنالك حكم
ذاتي لهذه المنطقه
ولا استبعد ان ان يعف ان تعف نفسه عن
عن استغلال هذه الفرصه لتحقيق بعض المكاسب
خاصه هنالك كانت هنالك توقعات بان تفعل
اثيوبيا ذات الشيء بان تستغل انشغال الجيش
السوداني بالمعارك الان وان تتمدد في
منطقه الفشل كل الاحتمالات وارده في حاله
الحرب واستمرار بهذه الطريقه وانشغال
الحكومه بمطارده المتمردين المتمردين
الدعم السريع ان تحاول بعض الاطراف اذا
كانت اطراف مجاوره او اطراف محليه ان
تستغل هذا الوضع لمصلحته شكرا جزيلا لك
ضياء الدين بلال على حضورك معنا هنا شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
في لبنان عززت قوات الطوارئ الدوليه
العامله في جنوب البلاد المعروفه باسم
اليونيفال عززت من انتشار افرادها في
المنطقه للفصل بين افراد الجيشين اللبناني
والاسرائيلي وقد حثت قوات اليونيفال جميع
الاطراف على ضبط النفس واستخدام اليات
التنسيق ياتي ذلك على خلفيه الاستنفار بين
الطرفين بعدما القت القوات الاسرائيليه
قنابل مسيله للدموع على مواطنين لبنانيين
تجمعوا للاحتجاج على تجريف الاراضي
الزراعيه من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه وقد
اعلن الجيش اللبناني ان قوته نفذت انتشارا
في المنطقه الحدوديه في كفر شوبا بمواجهه
القوات الاسرائيليه
هذا وقد قال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الهدوء
عاد الى جبل الروس بفرشوبه في مزارع شبعه
على الحدود مع لبنان بعد حاله التوتر التي
شهدتها المنطقه صباح اليوم واكد الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه استخدم وسائل لتفريق
متظاهرين لبنانيين قال انهم حاولوا تخريب
عوائق اقامها الجيش في المنطقه في الايام
الاخيره كما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
عناصر من الجيش اللبناني في المنطقه وجهت
مدافع صاروخيه باتجاه القوات الاسرائيليه
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر عسكريه
اسرائيليه ان اعمال التجريف التي جرت في
المنطقه كانت في الجهه الواقعه تحت
السيطره الاسرائيليه بالتنسيق مع قوات
اليونيفر
ينضم الينا من باريس دكتور زياد ماجد
والساده العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه بباريس اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور هل
يمكن ان تتطور هذه الاحداث الى ما هو اخطر
اعتقد في المرحله الحاليه هناك تبادل
رسائل يشير الى ان الطرفين يفضلان عدم
تدهور الامور كان لافتا ان حزب الله لم
ينتشر مباشره بل ترك الجيش اللبناني يقوم
بهذه المهمه وان سكان مدنيين من المنطقه
هم من تصدى للقوات الاسرائيليه التي حاولت
التعدي على اراضي زراعيه
وارادت بدورها ايضا ان ترسل رساله ان
مساله الحدود ما زالت قائمه وان اسرائيل
تراقب ما يجري ربطا بالملف الايراني وربطا
بتطورات المنطقه ككل اعتقد انه تبادل
الرسائل ضمن اطار توتر محدود لكن طبعا اذا
تطورت الامور اكثر فيما يتعلق بالشان
النووي الايراني او
بسياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الاكثر تطرفا
بتاريخ اسرائيل ربما تصبح
الحاله اكثر من ذلك بكثير ولكن هذه
الرسائل التي تشير اليها امتزجت
بتساؤلات شبه مدينه لقوات اليونيفل هل
فيها بعض الوجاهه
طبعا القوات
المفترض بها على الدوام ان تتدخل لمنع اي
خرق للقرارات الدوليه التي تسري على
الحدود اللبنانيه كان هناك بطئ البارحه
وقبل البارحه حين بدات التوتر بتدخلها ثم
راقبت الامور عوض ان تكون حائلا بين
الاسرائيليين الجنود الاسرائيليين
والمدنيين اللبنانيين ثم تدخلت اخيرا ربما
اريد ايضا ان يظهر دورها بشكل
وهذا ما دفع
ها لتخفيض النزاع هناك ملاحظات تواجهها
على بطء تحرك اليونيفال لكن ايضا هناك
مسائل تتخطى صلاحيات اليونيفال وترتبط
بدوله اسرائيل من جهه وبالرسائل التي يود
حزب الله ارسالها وقد سبق ان شهدت الحدود
توترات بسبب مناورات عسكريه اسرائيليه
هجوميه رد عليها حزب الله حزب الله ايضا
وهذا يظهر اننا في حلقه من تبادل
التهديدات من دون الوصول بعد الى حد تفجير
الصراع او الاشتباك المباشر الى جانب
الاشارات الاقليميه التي ذكرتها هل تعتقد
بان ايضا سواء الحكومه الاسرائيليه او
الحكومه اللبنانيه لها من المشاكل
الداخليه ما يغنيها عن اي تعقيد اكثر في
الموقف هناك
من الجانب الاسرائيلي الحكومه المتطرفه
الحاليه تريد ان تظهر انها جاهزه للحرب
والقتال على مختلف الجبهات طبعا قد لا
تترجم ذلك لكنها تقول الامريكيين تحركوا
تجاه ايران قبل ان تتدهور الامور اكثر
هناك عمليه ابتزاز على هذا الصعيد من
الجانب اللبناني بين الانهيار الاقتصادي
الكبير ومعاناه اللبنانيين عامه بما في
ذلك طبعا سكان الجنوب اللبناني لا اعتقد
ان هناك مصلحه في التصعيد لكن في ظل غياب
اي توافق على رئاسه الجمهوريه وفي ظل عوده
الحديث الان عن كون قائد الجيش مرشح
للرئاسه ربما ما يجري هو محاوله لاختبار
نياته من قبل اطراف مثل حزب الله او من
قبل يعني الوضع اللبناني عامه ما هو هامش
تحركه كيف سيدير حاله من التوتر على هذا
الصعيد اعتقد هناك امور داخليه تنعكس طبعا
على ما يج ري في الحدود لكن الزياره
الامريكيه للمنطقه والقول باحتمال الوصول
الى اتفاق مؤقت بين واشنطن وطهران حول
المساله النوويه هي بلا شك من العناصر
المؤثره على ما يجري في منطقه العرقوب
وعلى الحدود الجنوبيه شكرا لك دكتور زياد
ماجد من باريس
[موسيقى]
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
القوات الاوكرانيه بدات في شن هجومها
المضاد منذ خمسه ايام مشيرا الى تكبدها
خسائر كبيره في صفوفها حسب قولها وخلال
مؤتمر صحفي عقده في سوتشي شدد بوتين على
ان القوات الاوكرانيه فشلت في تحقيق
اهدافها في المحاور القتاليه كافه
يمكن التاكيد على وجه اليقين ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيه قد بدا والدليل على ذلك
استخدام الجيش الاوكراني لاحتياطي
الاستراتيجي لم تحقق القوات الاوكرانيه
اهدافها على اي مما محاور العمليات
القتاليه وهذا امر جلي للغايه نرصد هذه
الايام خسائر هائله في صفوف قوات النظام
الاوكراني اود الاشاره الى ان هذه الماساه
سببها الاحداث التي وقعت خلال الاعوام
الماضيه والمسؤوليه عن هذه الماساه تقع
كامله على عاتق نظامك في الحالي
اعلنا حاكم وقاطعه
الكسندر كوسيف اصابه ثلاثه مدنيين بجروح
اثر سقوط مسيره في مدينه فولونيج جنوب
غربي البلاد واشار المسؤول الروسي الى ان
المسيره استهدفت مبنى سكنيا وتسببت في
تدمير شقه بالكامل وان المصابين يخضعون
للعلاج بدوره قال الكرملين ان اجهزه
الاستخبارات الروسيه تحقق في هذا الهجوم
اما حاكم مقاطعه كورسكا الروسيه رومان
فاعلن عن سقوطي مسيره في محيط منشاه
النفطيه بمدينه كورسك واشار الى ان
المسيره سقطت في منطقه المستودع دون الحاق
اي اضرار ماديه او بشريه وفق تعبيرها
الحديث هو عن هجوم اوكراني المضاد يترجم
على الارض ما الذي تظهره خرائط المعارك
اين تدور المعارك وما اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه نتابع
بعد قرابه عام ونصف من القتال باتت القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على قرابه 14% من مساحه
اوكرانيا السيطره الروسيه الان متمركزه في
الشريط الجنوبي الشرقي من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بين عملياتك وسيطره واستعاده
السيطره يثبت شكل الخريطه هناك لكن منذ
اسابيع والحديث يتردد عن هجوم اوكراني
مضاد يقول الرئيس الروسي ان اوكرانيا بدات
هذا الهجوم لكنها لم تحقق ايا من اهدافه
منذ ايام تؤكد كييف انها لم تبدا بعد هذا
هجوم فيه كثير كلام عن الدعم الغربي تلك
دول لا تؤيد ان تنفذ القوات الاوكرانيه
هجمات داخل العمق الروسي وبناء على التحفظ
الغربي هذا تؤكد اوكرانيا ان ضرباتها في
الاراضي الروسيه لم ولن تنفذ باسلحه غربيه
الهدف هو ان داعمي اوكرانيا لا يريدون
الدخول في مواجهه مباشره مع موس
في الميدان تتجه الانظار الى لوغانس
كودونيتس وخيرسون وفي العمق القرم شبه
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
تؤكد اوكرانيا انها لم ولن تتنازل عنها
لكن ماذا سيستهدف الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
منذ اشهر قليله تتعرض مقاطعات روسيا على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا الى هجمات حدود تمتد
الى قربه 2200 كم تتوزع الهجمات على هذا
الشريط الطويل بين صواريخها ومسيرات قادمه
من اوكرانيا او مقاتلين على الارض هناك
مناهضين لموسكو تدعمهم كيف ينفذون عمليات
ضد الجنود الروس لم تعد بالجرود الروسيه
وحدها التي تتعرض لتلك الهجمات ما وراء
بيلو جرود تدخل مقاطعه فورونيج في دائره
الاستهداف هكذا تصبح مقاطعه الحدود
الجنوبيه الغربيه من روسيا في دائره النار
تلك مقاطعه تزيد مساحتها على 1200 كم
ذلك رقم لا يكاد يذكر من مساحه روسيا الا
ان الخاصره الجنوبيه الغربيه من البلاد لا
تبدو مستقره كما كان عليه الحال قبل
فبراير من العام الماضي تلك خاصره لا تبعد
كثيرا عن العاصمه موسكو التي تعرضت لهجمات
سابقا لم تتبنها اوكرانيا هكذا تسير الحرب
تتحرك خريطه المشهد الميداني الان بعد ان
كانت الاعين والحسابات العسكريه محدوده في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اصبح العمق الروسي
داخل دائره التوتر المتصاعد فاي صيف سيكون
على الطرفي الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا الان من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد ليسحنى اهلا وسهلا
بك
بوتين يقول الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بدا
هل من مؤشرات تؤكد فعلا ذلك
محمد هناك خطابين اساسيين على الساحه يعني
هناك خطاب رسمي الاعلى فيه هو مقاله
الرئيس بوتين يليه وزير الدفاع على ان
الهجوم بدا وهناك انجازات عسكريه وصمت
كامل وشامل من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وحتى
الحكومه الاوكرانيه الهجوم الذي ينتظره
الكل سوف لن يكون ذلك الهجوم الكبير
والسريع يعني بكل القوى التي حضرتها
اوكرانيا هذه المرحله هي مرحله الاستطلاع
يعني كما يقال
يعني هي مرحله تحضير الارضيه عبر على سبيل
المثال كما اتى في التقرير ضرب الداخل خلق
بلبله في داخل الروسي ضرب العمق ضرب كل ما
له علاقه باللوجستيه الروسيه وبالتالي
المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله جص النبض على
جبهه بطول 9 كيلو متر لمعرفه امكنه
نقاط الضعف وبالتالي التراكمات من
النجاحات اليوم دائما في اول مرحله من
الحرب من يهاجم هو الذي يتكبت الخسائر
الاكبر خاصه ان روسيا كان لديها الوقت
لتحضير بنيه دفاعيه كامله وشامله على طول
الجبهه ككل الان وقت حلت اشهر الصيف ما
المتوقع في سير المعارك
هناك ازمه المصداقيه لدى اوكرانيا لديها
كل شيء عليها ان تحقق شيء معين الانجاز
ياتينا بواقع امني واستراتيجي على الصعيد
الاوكراني والاوروبي والفشل قد ياتي بشيء
مهم جدا يعني يؤدي الى نسف كل المنظومه
الامنيه يجب ان يكون هناك نصر اوكراني
كافي لتبرير هذا التجهيز وهذه الاهتمام
الغربي من النيتو من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي الزام الحكومه الروسيه
نتحدث عن رئيس بوتين الزامها الى وقف وقف
نار الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات هذا الامر
يجب ان يكون كبير جدا وهذا لن يحصل الا
اذا حصل في منطقه
توك ماك ميليتو بول وبالتالي ضرب الجسر
البري الذي يعتبر العمود الفقري لك ل
مشروع الرئيس بوتين عندما ضم الاقاليم
الاربعه
يعني مثلما تابعنا قبل قليل الخارطه لو
اردنا ان نقول باختصار الان الميزان
العسكري كيف يبدو ماذا نقول
ليس هناك من ميزان عسكري بالمطلق الميزان
العسكري هو لصالح روسيه يبدو اليوم من
ينتصر هو في الكيف في ايه طريقه وفي موضوع
المفاجاه محمد المفاجاه غائبه عن المسرح
الاوكراني المفاجاه الاستراتيجيه الكل
يعرف اين الهجوم الكل يعرف ماذا حضر ولكن
اليوم الحديث عن المفاجات التكتيكيه عن
نقاط الضعف في عده اماكن اذا تراكمت مع
بعضها قد تؤدي الى
مكسب استراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك العميل من
بيروت
[موسيقى]
بل المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي في البيت الابيض ان روسيا ستبني
مصنعا للمسيرات الايرانيه على اراضيها
وسيعمل بكامل طاقته مطلع مايوير العام
المقبل تصريحات جون كيربي تزامنت مع بيان
نشرته الخارجيه الامريكيه بشان النشره
التحذيريه التي صدرت عن وزارات الخزانه
والعدل والتجاره لتنبيه المجتمع الدولي
وتحذيره من التعاون مع ايران في برنامجها
لصناعه المسيرات من جهه اخرى اكدت بجين
وموسكو توسيعه تعاونهم العسكري بعد
اجتماعا عبر الفيديو بين رئيسي هيئه اركان
البلدين
تتقرب من روسيا تعاقب او تعاقب اكثر يبدو
ان هذا هو منطق الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
في التعامل مع كل من يتعاون مع موسكو هذه
الايام واذا تعلق الامر بالتعاون العسكري
فتلك الطعم الكبرى بعواقب وخيمه محتمله
روسيا ستكون قادره على انتاج سيارات
ايرانيه على اراضيها العمل مقبل الاعلان
الاتهام جاء على لسان المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كيربي
اسهب في التفاصيل استنادا لتقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه قال ان روسيا تتلقى
مواد من ايران لبناء مصنع للمسيرات مضيفا
ان المنشاه قد تتمكن من العمل بطاقاتها
الكامله مطلع ما يل المقبل وقد اوضحت
الحكومه الامريكيه بصوره من الاقمار
الصناعيه ان المصنع سيكون في منطقه
الاقتصاديه وتقع على نحو 900 كيلومتر شرق
موسكو حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والطادت
العلاقات اكثر بين موسكو وطهران وزادت من
غضب الولايات المتحده التي تكرر اتهامها
لطهران بتزويد موسكو بالمسيرات كل
المعلومات والارقام المرتبطه بهذا الموضوع
مصادرها غربيه حسب التايمز البريطانيه
تملك روسيا اكثر من 2000 مسيره ايرانيه من
جيل شاهد لديها شاهد 136 وهي نسخه من
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تستطيع التحليق
لمسافه
2500 كيلومتر وقد اتهمت كييف موسكو بتسلم
مسيرات شاهد
229 ولكن لا يوجد اي دليل مادي على
استخدامها في الحرب الدائره من جههها ذكرت
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه حصول روسيا على
مسيرات مهاجر سته التي يمكن ان تحمل
اربعين كيلو جراما من المت وتصل سرعتها
الى 200 كيلومتر في الساعه كثيره خطوات
واشنط لعرقله برنامج ايران لصناعه
المسيرات واخرها بيان الخارجيه الذي جاء
فيه ان وزارات العدل والتجاره والخزانه
اصدرت نشره تحذيريه لتنبيه المجتمع الدولي
والقطاع الخاص للتهديد الذي يشكله هذا
البرنامج وقدم التوجيهات وتوصيات للمصنعين
والموزعين والمؤسسات الماليه لاخذها في
الحسبان من اجل ضمان الامتثال للضوابط
القانونيه والتجنب المساهمه دون قصد في
البرنامج الايراني للمسيرات ايضا في عين
العاصفه الامريكيه وهذا الاجتماع عبر
الفيديو بين الرئيس هيئه الاركان الروسيه
ونظيره الصيني ماده اخرى للانتقادات
والاتهامات اكد فاليري كريسيموف
لليوتينلي الناموسكو وبيجين ستواصلان
التوسع في تعاونهم العسكري اللقاء كان منا
لتوجيه الدعوه لروسيا لمشاركه في تدريب
عسكري ستنظمه الصين اخر تدريب بينهما يعود
الى الثلاثاء الماضي فقط سياره دوريه جويه
عسكريه مشتركه فوق بحري اليابان والصين
الشرقي وسط ادانات دول الجوار حلفت واشنطن
الخصمان السابقان في زمن الحرب البارده
بعث الدفء في علاقاتهما منذ عشر سنوات
وزاد الود المدروس بعد الحرب في اوكرانيا
مظالم العقوبات والسياسات الامريكيه قد
تجمع الاضداد وتعمق علاقات تؤرق واشنطن
جدا
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نسلط اليوم الضوء على
التطور الاحدث في ملف طالبي اللجوء وذلك
بعد توصل وزراء داخليه دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي لاتفاق بشان نصين رئيسيين ضمن
اصلاح نظام الهجره نستعرض خريطه المواقف
الاوروبيه في هذا الموضوع حيال الاتفاق
تحديدا والذي تطلبت الموافقه عليه تطلبت
اغلبيه الدول التي تمثل 65% من سكان
التقدم وجاء بعد سنوات من الخلاف على
سياسه الهجره والوجوب ايطاليا واليونان
مثلا
انضمت الى هذا الاتفاق بعد مفاوضات مضنيه
صوتت بولندا والمجر ضد هذه المقترحات او
بنود الاتفاق بينما امتنعت بلغاريا ومالطا
وليتوانيا وسلوفانيا سلوفاكيا عفوا امتنعت
كلها عن التصويت يلزم الاتفاق الدول
الاعضاء بانشاء مراكز على الحدود الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي الحدود البريه والمطارات
خصوصا للمهاجرين الذين لديهم فرصه ضئيله
احصائيا للحصول على اللجوء الهدف من وراء
ذلك هو عدم دخول هؤلاء اراضي الاتحاد
الاوروبي على ان تخضع طلبات لجوئهم لفحص
سريع من اجل تسهيل عودتهم الى بلدهم
الاصلي او بلد العبور اجراء يتطلب سته
اشهر كحد اقصى كما تم الاتفاق على ذلك
تطبق الاجراءات على طالبيه اللجوء من
بلدان يقل في الاتحاد الاوروبي معدل
الاعترافي بوضع مواطنيها كلاجئين عن عشرين
بالمئه يتعلق هذا مثلا بمواطني تركيا او
الهند او تونس او صربيا او البانيا
ويفتح الاتفاق المجال امام مفاوضات في
البرلمان الاوروبي بغيه تبني اصلاح نظام
الهجره واللجوء قبل الانتخابات انتخابات
الاتحاد الاوروبي انتخاب البرلمان
الاوروبي العام المقبل لكن ماذا عن
الانتقادات الموجهه لهذا الاتفاق
ترى المجرى مثلا ان اليه التوزيع الجديده
لطالبي الهجوم من شانها ان تسمح لمهاجرين
غير شرعيين او حتى مهربين البشر الذين
احضروهم الى اوروبا باتخاذ القرار بشان من
يعيش في اوروبا
منظمه اوكس فاما الخيريه مثلا برغبه
الاتحاد الاوروبي باحتجاز طالبي الوجود
وخاصه الاطفال فيما يشبه السجون على حدود
اوروبا لكن المفوضيه الاوروبيه ترى
الاجراء انسانيه وفي اطار الخلافات
والتباينات ترفض دول في شرق الاتحاد
الاوروبي مثل بولندا والمجر استضافه اي
شخص من منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
ذات الاغلبيه المسلمه بطبيعه الحال من
النقاط المثيره للجدل ولم يتم الاتفاق
عليها في الترتيبات الاوروبيه الاخيره هي
وضع قائمه للبلدان الثالث او تسمى هكذا
البلدان الثالثه او البلدان الامنه اي تلك
التي ينقل اليها من يعتبر طلب لجوءهم غير
مقبول وتتهم مجموعات الخضر وتكتلات اليسار
في البرلمان الاوروبي تتهم الدول الاعضاء
بانها استسلمت لليمين المتطرف وسط مخاوف
من مخاطر ان
كبير الباحثين في مركز
مارتنز للدراسات الاوروبيه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل تعتقد بان هذه الاتفاقات الجديده تسير
باوروبا اكثر نحو اليمين
كلا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق
ليله امس والذي اتفق عليه وزراء داخليه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يتعلق بتوضيح المسؤوليه
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي من يهتم بطالبي
اللجوء عند وصولهم مثلا وايضا يقوم
باتخاذ الاجراءات الضروريه
ويحسن ايضا فكره
الدعم الذي
ويسمى مساله تشارك العباء فيما يتعلق بمن
يهتم بطالبيه اللجوء في مختلف الظروف لا
اعتقد حقيقه ان الامر يتعلق بنقل اوروبا
نحو اليمين او اقصى اليمين على ذكر تشارك
الذي اشرت اليه الاتفاق يتحدث عن نصيب كل
دوله من اعداد معينه من اللاجئين والدوله
التي ترفض عليها ان تدفع 20 الف يورو
مقابل كل لاجئ اذا رفضت هل تعتقد بان هذه
مساله عمليه
هي نوع من التجربه
سنرى اذا ما كانت ستكون ناجحه انا لست
متاكده من نجاحها امل انها ستنجح
[موسيقى]
ومبلغ العشرين الف يورو الذي تم الاتفاق
عليه كان طريقه لوصولي الى نوع من التسويه
بين دول الاعضاء
بالتالي اعتقد ان جميع يامل انهم ستكونوا
طريقه ناجعه
بالنسبه لما يسمى
الدول الثالثه التي يعاد اليها بعض
اللاجئين الذين لا يقبلون في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ووقعت الاشاره الى البانيا وتونس
هل هل هذه الفكره مفهومه
فكره
اعاده الاشخاص او طالبيه اللجوء الى دول
العبور هل هذا ما تسال عنه
اعتقد ان فكره اعاده من لا يحق لهم طلب
اللجوء هذا ليس بالامر الجديد هذه كانت
هذا كان امرا موجودا الامل ان هذا الاتفاق
سيسهل عوده من لا يحق لهم طلب اللجوء الى
دول امنه يتمتعون فيها بالحمايه وبالتالي
تعيدهم الى بلادهم الاصليه بالتالي هو
الامر ليس بالجديد الغريب نوعا ما ان الان
الحديث الاوروبي لا يشير الى اربعه ملايين
اوكرانيا تقريبا بينما بضعت الاف ياتون من
تونس او من ليبيا في منطقه المتوسط نحو
اليونان او نحو ايطاليا اصبحت قضيه كبرى
هل من تفسير
نعم نعم بالتاكيد
هنالك حرب قاسيه وحشيه تحصل في اوكرانيا
والتعاطف تعاطف الجمهور الاوروبي والساسه
الاوروبيه كان واضحا منذ البدايه تجاه
الاوكرانيين وخاصه في كما قلت اتجاه
الاوكرانيين بالتالي ليس هنالك اي تردد
على الاطلاق في منحي الحمايه المؤقته لاي
اوكراني وايضا في معظمه الدول الاوروبيه
او للطرب من لاي شخص من دوله ثالثه كان
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه عند نشوب الحرب
الفرق بين اوكرانيا وتونس امر واضح ليس
هنالك حرب في تونس مثلا بالتالي فان
الافراد
ظروفهم ظروف اي مواطن تونسي مثلا سيتم
دراستها والبحث بها اعتقد انه
بالتالي بالتالي الامر يختلف مع
الاوكرانيين الذين تعطى لهم موافقه واضحه
وشكرا لك كبير الباحثين في مركز مارتنز
للدراسات الاوروبيه من بروكسل
اذا تابعنا بعض بنود الاتفاقيه الاوروبيه
بخصوص ملف ايطالي اللجوء والجدل حوله في
الحلقه الاحدث لمحنه الطالبيه اللجوء قالت
السلطات الاسبانيه اليوم ان مهاجرين اثنين
غرقا وان ثالثا هو في حاله حرجه بعد ان
امرهم اشخاص يقودون قاربين بالسباحه الى
الشاطر قال المكتب الاقليمي للحكومه
المركزيه ان قاربين يحملان على متنهما 137
طالب لجوء بينهم ثلاثه اطفال على الاقل
كان بالقرب من سواحل مدينه الميريا البحر
المتوسط صباح اليوم الجمعه حين اجبرهم
قائداء القاربين على السباحه الى الشاطئ
الامل كل الامل ان تنتهي محنه الكثير من
الناس من من اجبرتهم الصعوبات في اوطانهم
على اللجوء الى خيارات
تكلفهم ارواحهم احيانا او في اغلب الاحيان
دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]